zeitreisen was was zeitreisen ist das
nicht eine erfindung von hollywood
genauso wie zombies und laserschwerter
und beamern ist das nicht eine
wissenschaftssendung was passiert hahaha
sehr witzig zeitreise gibt es nicht das
ist alles nur fake hier intro
täglich okay sorry könnten können wir
die farbe wieder danke am 21 10 2015 war
back to the future tag im klassiker back
to the future 2 reist marty mcfly mit
seinem delorean ins jahr 2015 und zwar
genau zum 21 oktober und das war
natürlich anlass für viele leute den
film und seine elemente zu feiern
nike zeigte zum beispiel das erste mal
die berüchtigten schuhe die sich selber
zusammenschnüren können ab 2016 sollen
diese dann zu kaufen sein
und die erlöse gehen an die forschung
gegen parkinson daumen nach oben geile
aktion und das technikunternehmen imtech
stellte mal wieder eine neue version
ihres haver boards vor und dabei war wie
immer tony hawk es war einfach ein sehr
cooler tag für film und wissenschaft
fans aber das größte feature aus dem
film haben wir immer noch nicht
können wir wirklich in der zeit reisen
die antwort ist erstaunlicherweise ja
wie alle reisen in der zeit jetzt gerade
mit einer geschwindigkeit von genau
einer sekunde pro sekunde
okay zugegeben das klingt jetzt nicht
besonders aufregend aber wir müssen uns
erst mal bewusst machen wie zeit
eigentlich funktioniert so etwas wie
eine universelle zeit gibt es zum
beispiel nicht jedes atom und damit im
größeren sinne jeder mensch hat seine
eigene zeit seine eigene uhr
und diese zeit bewegt sich in relation
zu anderen zeiten schneller oder eben
langsamer je nachdem wie schnell man
sich durch den raum bewegt und wie viel
gravitation man erfährt das ist die
einsteinsche relativitätstheorie
konkret heißt das wenn du einmal um den
block spazieren gehst bist du danach
circa drei femtosekunden jünger als wenn
du dich nicht bewegt hättest gut daran
haben wir es noch nicht wirklich viel
aber gehen wir doch mal einen schritt
weiter astronauten bewegen sich schnell
oder die iss rast mit 27.000 600
kilometern pro stunde über unsere köpfe
hinweg
und je länger sich astronauten in der
iss mit dieser geschwindigkeit bewegen
desto jünger werden sie im vergleich zu
uns auf der erde
den rekord hält im moment der russische
astronaut sergej krikaljow der über 800
tage im orbit war und durch die
jahrelange geschwindigkeit ganze 0,02
sekunden jünger ist
oder man kann es auch so ausdrücken dass
er durch seinen aufenthalt auf der ss
0,02 sekunden in die zukunft gereist ist
okay gut ich merke schon das bringt
alles nichts wir wollen nämlich ein paar
sekunden sondern jahrzehnte oder
jahrhunderte in die zukunft reisen um
wirklich weit in die zukunft reisen zu
können müsste man sich schon annähernd
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen wenn du
zum beispiel zehn jahre lang mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 99,9999 95 prozent
der lichtgeschwindigkeit reisen könntest
dann würdest du mir an 3015 ankommen du
hättest 1000 jahre überlebt obwohl nur
zehn jahre im raumschiff fast und
gravitation hat übrigens genau denselben
effekt auf einem planeten der um ein
riesiges schwarzes loch mit einer
riesigen gravitation kreis vergeht die
zeit in relation langsamer wintersteller
wird das zum beispiel super dargestellt
dort vergehen für jede verbrachte stunde
auf einem exotischen planeten sieben
jahre auf der erde eine etwas kleinere
version davon können wir mit unseren
gps-satelliten erleben wenn sie um die
erde kreisen erfahren sie weniger
gravitation als wir auf der erde
deswegen müssen die uhren extra etwas
langsamer eingestellt werden
explodiert euer kopf schon zeitreisen
mit der einsteinschen
relativitätstheorie können etwas
verwirrend sein aber überlegt mal was
man alles damit anstellen könnte wie
sieht die welt in 1000 jahren aus wie
fortgeschritten sind wir inzwischen gibt
es noch krieg hunger und überwachung
oder haben wir uns die perfekte utopie
geschaffen
all das könnte man herausfinden ohne
tausend jahre warten zu müssen
aber wie wir aus der berühmten szene mit
matthew mcconaughey untersteller wissen
es kann auch sehr einsam sein in der
zukunft alle geliebten und verwandten in
der zukunft sind schon tot
und vielleicht ist es hier in 1000
jahren ja auch gar nicht so toll wer
weiß das schon
also kann man auch in der zeit
zurückreisen hier wird schon schwieriger
es gibt viele theorien wie man in die
vergangenheit reisen könnte aber keine
konnte bisher bewiesen werden
die meisten benötigen entweder unendlich
viel energie oder negative energie etwas
von dem niemand weiß wie man es
herstellt oder benutzt es gibt
allerdings eine methode die garantiert
funktioniert wenn man sich nach der
vergangenheit sehen schaut einfach mal
nachts in den sternenhimmel
das licht der sterne die wir sehen ist
tausende oder sogar millionen von jahren
gereist nur um genau in dieser sekunde
auf unsere netzhaut zu fallen
was wir sehen ist die vergangenheit und
eigentlich sind wir immer die
vergangenheit
alles was wir sehen sind photonen die
von etwas reflektiert wurden und dann in
unser auge fallen
und egal wo wir hinsehen das licht
musste erst von dort reflektiert werden
und dann zu uns kommen und das dauert
wenn man jetzt noch die zeit mit
einberechnet die unser gehirn benötigt
um das gesehene zu verarbeiten
dann leben wir ständig 23
hundertstelsekunden in der vergangenheit
wir können nie wirklich im hier und
jetzt leben alles was wir wahrnehmen ist
bereits passiert
aber hey das hat auch vorteile stellt
euch vor wir würden einen riesigen
spiegel im weltall platzieren der das
licht das von der erde kommt wieder
zurück reflektiert je nachdem in welcher
entfernen sich der spiegel befindet
könnten wir sehen was wir hier auf der
erdoberfläche gemacht haben vor fünf
minuten oder vor 1000 jahren das licht
das vergangene ereignisse berührt hat
fliegt immer noch überall im weltall
herum
man könnte jeden mord der
menschheitsgeschichte aufklären
zumindest die morde die tagsüber unter
freiem himmel statt gefunden haben
wir müssen nur ein spiel schneller
transportieren als das licht sich von
uns entfernt wir können also in die
zukunft reisen und in die vergangenheit
gucken nicht umgekehrt
aber vielleicht wollen wir auch gar
nicht in die vergangenheit reisen viele
paradox da stellen sich uns in den weg
wenn es um zeitreisen geht was zum
beispiel passiert wenn du in der zeit
zurückreist und dich selber tötet bevor
du wieder in die zeitmaschine einsteigen
kannst dann kannst du ja gar nicht mehr
die zeit zurückreisen um sich selber zu
töten
irgendwas kann nicht stimmen stephen
hawking behauptet dass die gesetze der
physik sich vor solchen paradox schützen
indem ein rückkopplungseffekt entsteht
sollte man jemals versuchen in der zeit
zurückzureisen wie der pfeifton von
lautsprechern so laut hawking bei
zeitreisen automatisch auch strahlung
mit in die vergangenheit geschickt
werden
diese strahlung kommt dann wieder in der
gegenwart an und verstärkt sich somit
selber immer wieder bis die zeitmaschine
zerstört wird
und selbst wenn wir alle unmöglichkeiten
und schwierigen frage ignorieren bleibt
immer noch der schmetterlingseffekt die
tatsache dass jede kleinste änderungen
den verlauf der dinge
katastrophal verändern kann jede aktion
höchst eine andere reaktion aus vor ein
paar wochen fragte die new york times
ihre leser auf twitter eine etwas
ungewöhnliche frage wenn du in der zeit
zurückreisen könntest würdest du adolf
hitler als baby töten
wenn man ein paar anderem trifft ist die
frage relativ leicht zu beantworten
würde man den zweiten weltkrieg und
damit den tod von millionen von menschen
im handel gegen ein kind verhindern
ja ja ich denke die meisten menschen
würden das tun allerdings verändert man
damit auch den lauf der zeit auf eine
sehr drastische art und weise und das
lässt sich einfach nicht abschätzen wie
ein alternativer zeit stark aussehen
würde würde vielleicht ein anderer noch
viel gefährlichere anführer die
nationalsozialisten in den krieg führen
oder würde der krieg nie stattfinden und
wir hätten niemals erfindungen wie den
computer das internet oder
nanotechnologie
viele erfindungen werden im krieg
gemacht und ich möchte nicht die
entscheidung treffen was wichtiger ist
menschenleben oder menschlicher
fortschritt
was meint ihr würdet ihr baby hitler
töten oder besser nicht
und mit welcher begründung schreibt eure
meinung unten in die kommentare ich bin
schon sehr gespannt was ihr zu dem thema
zu sagen habt ansonsten ein anderes
video von mir haben roboter ein
bewusstsein da geht es auch um die
zukunft vor allem von maschinen und
algorithmen in unserem alltag kam sehr
gut an wo ich euch auf jeden fall ans
herz legen viel spaß nahmen und bis bald
verrückt ich gucke jetzt glaube ich back
to the future 22